hd всім доброго вечора з вами знову
платформа та масивний петренко with nice
урочистості святі наук україни я і
модератор Володимир Страшко сьогодні знам
і навіть тикові є лена вдома вояка я
профі сильним психологом і душили будинком
українці де чим публічним де чим яко так
допомагаю людям і в мирному поверни години
ніби заходять собою зараз ціни прості
година для нас та параду я думаю буду дуже
слухаємо і для кожного з нас Олена
доброго до біса
вітаю україна
нібито справи як-як одеса
кажуть одесити ми між собою сумно
жартуємо
тривожність їх тому що вигляд у якому
жаху в якому пеклі живуть наші українці з
найгарячіших точок нашої країни господи
чи могли ми подумати ще недавно що
таке від торкнеться нас немає скажи
будь ласка це прямо настільки обману не
віриться тут щодо тихо у нас
навіть якщо так у нас вже звичні
і якісь вибух чеки на світанку ми
спокійно до них ставимося, бо вони
не носять руйнівний характер ти
знаєш
все ж таки знаєш в одесі годуються з
чутками та плітками і ми всі чекаємо
ми тривожно чекаємо хоч мені здається
ніколи не можна бути готовими до цього
слухаючи але я у нас правда суд із цитати
раз качалку наш вбивця тому що ті
люди за раз в Україні які вас серед
знаходиться в зоні десятками бойовики
харків-київ суща начальники чим тонша
регіону та люду які і тривожно чекають
на тесті може прапор у сулій з точки
zara психології
можемо йому якутського ти піших та інших
пояс немає ще й збувається вловив відпочинок та
у друга чому я задаються харчування про те
що ми вимагаємо різанини за видами мене
руками проти віч не до допомагаючи кусають
ніяк не стику його і скажи чесно про
важливо без таких приводів повідон і їсть їх
регіоні навіть нічого не травня тільки бог
заходь нічого розуміє нам як наприклад
на чернівці ободи там було якось ви
berkova
історія з аеродромів топтуни масового
цимбалів бидло стояк реакція ну ось ось
як в одесі, тобто у нас
піддавалися таким знаєш ну об'єктивно
незначним атакам військові об'єкти
там навіть немає технічних руйнувань не
говорячи вже слава богу про людські
жертвах хоч ось днями
мого сусіда колись знімала
сусідні комуні квартиру ось
розповіли що він потрапив під обстріл для
мене це настільки дико хочеться сказати
слухай людина все-таки за своєю суттю
тварина яка вважає себе розумними
мислячим і коли відбуваються такі моторошні
речі ми переходимо на існування
інстинктах найголовніший інстинкт це
все-таки інстинкт виживання та адреналін
цей нейромедіатор страху захисту
нападу він один із найпотужніших
тому
страх це найсильніша емоція яка
тримає знаєш що цікаво
найяскравіше емоції це сміх ми
заразливі емоції це смерть сміх
просто найдовше тримає цей рядок
людина може перебувати в цій емоції
дуже я тобі хочу сказати що ось
по собі це бачу і відчуваю я начебто
як розумна і аналізую ситуацію так
якщо мені у як села але і ви все одно
все не всі але люди які обивателі
дивані політики дивані аналітики ми
не розуміємо що відбувається і ми всі
знаходимося в дуже сильними
інформаційному потоці кожен щось
читає кожен щось аналізує і ось у
залежно від того, що ми шанували
для цього
історія з телефоном знаєш це зараз
така місцева штука яка година вибач
яка зараз відбувається ось наприклад у
мене там був учора ефіру дуже такий
важливий я щодня виходжу в ефіри
в інстаграмі в телеграмі я підтримую
велика кількість людей, тому що я
розумію що люди за самонавідний
апельсина те, що я говорила бутик
начитався він підключився до якогось
інформаційному полю інформаційному
потоку і він увійшов ось цей резонанс з
тими, хто це говорить з тими, хто це
написав степи то для чого ось це
написала вже розуміємо, що всі ці
інформаційні війни ведуться абсолютно
не дарма і ми на підключаючись до цього
потоку ми транслюємо та відчуваємо не
свої емоції не свої почуття якщо нам
розповіли що
якщо нам розповіли що все страшно треба
бігти ми починаємо бігти, а якщо хтось
сказав слухай та все буде добре ну
подивися у вікно все ж таки тихо все
спокійно ми заспокоюємося і
тут немає єдиного розуміння кому як от
через те, що там я лідер думок мені
весь час питає Олена порадьте
щось немає такої поради ніхто не має права
радити навіть близьким навіть друзям
знаєш чому тому що у кожного своя
воля і у кожного своя ну я не говорю я
не не фаталіст у сенсі в суть кожного
своя доля яка призначена ось
треба було читати по руці, бо навіть
лінії на руці якщо ми беремо хіромантію
вони змінюються в залежності від того, як
ми діємо ми з'ясуємо я все-таки
керуючись принципом
причинно-наслідкового зв'язку і ось у цьому
сенсі у нас своя доля кожна людина
він опинився в тій чи іншій точці на
карті життя тому що трошки йому так
була вирішена тому, що ця карма його
предків а тому що тут і зараз це
був
ланцюжок його дій і тому те що
добре для мене щось погано для когось і
навпаки
тому що кожен з нас опинився в цих
точках чому так я зараз дуже часто я
дуже хочу, щоб мене тільки почути
або чую такі ось фраза це ж
несправедливо
справедливість вона носить вищий
порядок ніж тут і зараз люди до
жаль це не так оцінюють не
вважають що ось вони ми всі заслуговуємо
світу ми всі заслуговуємо на любов свої
заважати шансом на народження але далі ми
вже робимо певні кроки, які ми
заслуговуємо щось і обсе кажу ось
дивіться ви коли заробляли не те що
вам належала, коли ви обманювали
коли ви зраджували коли ви брехали своїм
дітям коли ви обирали
зрадити себе надати когось це вже
було несправедливим не стосовно
собі не стосовно інших і коли
тут зараз ми знаходимося в таких
умовах ми як мінімум не знаємо куди
нас розгорне у мене вчора була дівчинка
вона звернулася за допомогою льону і
заклепку ви задихаючись у мене ось
панічна атака я з нею розмовляю
іграшки вона давайте ось зараз
пропонує і всім відчути що
хорошого вам дала це війна на рік що
може бути хороший ігри стоп ось що ви
зараз не робите з того, що ви робили
до війни битої я так не люблю свою
роботу і так рада що немає роботи зараз
слухай на величезну кількість людей
зараз знаходяться в
благословенної тиші від того, що було
раніше ось як це не страшно звучить я
розмовляла зі своїм другом він пережив
на війну у придністров'ї та angry і ти
знаєш коли я був у бункері зі своїми
батьками я пам'ятаю, що ми з братом були
щасливі що війна тому що ми з
батьками
теж така глибока д приватна за раз і
ноги у себе на донці що я проводжу цілий
день за своїм сином вчені мужі його
просто умовах випадкового жити а там вже
нехай і навіки праворуч і я покараю вже про
будні на вид на вихідних азарів просто
на меншому виборі even гіркоти за раз не
здається зараз нова йому 2 раката
вінчі розумі а в торренті він все ранить
за тату тут мама тут ми постінора йому
зараз робота підніматися
в плюс можна сказати а я бути
вдалого почеку стоп це не цинічно на
насправді знає, що зараз відбувається
що ви не відбувалося карантин це було
легке таке тренування рекламне
пауза всіх бубниш під самому початку все
були в дуже сильному страху саме через
виживання тому що ніхто не знав все
намалювали собі дикі
фантасмагоричні ідеї без вірусу
які знищили зжере типу еболи
потім ми розібралися а не так все
страшно, але тут і зараз і потім
карантин обійшовся з найстрашнішим що
не можна без подорожувати про неї або
треба вакцинуватися ну таке, а ось
тут і зараз реальний страх і ми всі
оновлюємося щодня тому що ніхто
не знає чи буде це завтра і тут.
зараз наше найголовніше завдання своїм
сьогоднішнім днем ​​своїми сьогоднішніми
думками вчинками ідеями прокладати
шлях у наші завтра і ось ми зараз
творимо
майбутню реальність ось
віруюча людина або невіруючий але
все-таки навіть агностики та атеїсти вони
особливо в стані загрози життю
звертаються до чогось вищого і от якщо
ми говоримо про це у всіх релігіях є
що по-різному просто 100 трактується що
на шостий день створив бог людини за
образу і подобі своєму, що це означає
це означає, що ми всі творці своєї
реальності ми такі ж, тобто ми всі
творимо ми творимо те що у нас
відбувається і ось тут і зараз дуже
важливо перебувати весь час у стані
ось що я творю і ось ти твориш історію
своїх взаєминах зі своїм сином
ось у тебе тут і зараз є
можливість закласти в нього цінності
тому що наші діти потім так само як і
ми несемо ці цінності по життю та
замість того, щоб сидіти в новинних
каналах, які ми ж зливаємо тонни
енергії перебуваючи підключаючись до цього
дикому інформаційному полю російські
канали українські канали я за ці дні за
перші кілька днів перестала читати
новини тому що послухай у них не див
послуг ми зараз
висновок що вантажиться з інтернету
удару slayer так
коли ми
перші дні не розуміли, що відбувається і
підключалися ось до цього інформаційного
полю страху
страх це дико руйнівна сила для
організму я психосоматолог це в
каталозі які працюють із тілом
використовую із хворобами тому що психіка
закладає причину для
хвороб всі наші хвороби вони від не
перенесених травм та
ось якщо ти подивишся що переважне
більшість людей зараз вони завмерли вони
не хворіють і хіт нічого у себе в stories
можна повернути кабінет нитка виду немає його
з правда ними в залі і ніхто відсоток
гори чирі ви ласих на вітер чушок була
багата та й зараз єдине на що
скаржаться люди це те, що дуже сильно
болить голова від дикої кількості
інформації дикої кількості страху
який навколо ми ж всі підключені
дуже багато експериментів які там на
щурів на мишах на собаках на вівцях на
мурах, які доводять наскільки ми
всі підключені до єдиного людського
поле ось невеликий чоловічок
які взаємодіють один з одним на
рівні вібрації на рівні мислеформ якщо
образів і ось на західній Україні
тихо-спокійно слава богу, але не знаходиться
у такому ж панічному жаху
якому перебуває інша частина України та
навіть не тому, що вони дивляться новину
принижувати їх вони можуть вийти на вулицю
молотова і всі кажуть послухайте мені
подобається зараз всі бачили генплан живі
вами україни, і там немає західної україни
заспокоїться тому все ще втечу
західну Україну але вони панічно бояться
тому що енергополе України вона єдина
і ми всі ось це ось нація ми один з
другом спілкуємося на рівні на форумі
образи і нас усіх качаючи, але не здається
що знаєш я така історія яко
заручницях нові але можна кожна людина
що нехай і ну читають 7 кілограм
каналу ти знаєш як переживаєш за
свою футбольну команду ну я не знаю
дошки киця грубо
по і найняли хто там вашого їх успіх для
техніку російську розриву roar візерунком
або техніку там bomiko з місця взяла
чорт взяв її лист studio to the та це
дуже вас ножі і гасити на знаходиться в
зоні попливу в заговеня спілкування на
фронті напевно щось на фронті взагалі
ніде його слухаючи навіть якщо ти президент
схоже ти нічого не можеш зробити
давай мені зараз дуже
не сумно не смішно я навіть не знаю це
вершина інші емоції
дивно що переживає ці два
чувака які не все йде не за планом
тому що люди виявляються вносять свої
корективи
тому я слідую в перестаньте думати
що ви можете на щось впливати ось на
що ви можете впливати тільки на своє
серце ось це у ваших силах вирощувати
ось цей стан кохання транслювати
його як мінімум своїм домашнім особливо
у своїх дітях стежити і панічно бояться
того що відбувається вони ж не розуміють
що відбувається papas мами і лаються
тато з мамою бояться redbet мама і все у
дітей страх тому що це загрожує
безпеки і справді
абсолютно все одно мама боїться тому
що тато змінюємо що тато розлучається
або тому що буде війна дітям просто
страшно тому, що вони довіряють нам це
ось наш обов'язок батьківський
тримати себе в спокій у світі заради
наших дітей, тому що я зараз скажу
дуже страшну річ ну якщо нам судилося
померти
судячи з усього, ми помремо дуже швидко
ну ось якщо це така ось град така
атака з повітря це страх ніколи не
думала, що мені доведеться про це думати і
завжди ж говорили про те, що Україна
дуже мирна геополітична країна
виявляється так ми ж не далекий схід
але якщо це станеться
болісна смерть вона менша за шанси
коли ось якщо ти проживеш усередині ось
це ось переживання що я померла людина
ти не боляче не страшно це не це не
страшно насправді але зате ми в
чеканні цієї смерті втрачаємо можливість
обійматися зі своїми рідними є
смачну їжу, яка є ще дугу читати
казки своїм дітям займатися сексом зі
своїми улюбленими людьми дивитися фільми
дивитися безглузді ролики читати якісь
адже книжки цього часу не було коли
ми бігли гроші все гавкати сьогодні
тільки приколювати Альона де там ці
продавці тренінгів особистісного зростання
вам найкращий тренінг по виходу з
зони комфорту війна приголомшливий тренер
це тренер виходу із зони комфорту та
кохання ось пам'ятаєш недавно всі обговорювали
фільму даунс цибулі
чудово для мене найголовніше сцена
цього фільму в кінці коли ті люди
яким треба було бути разом лишилися
адже помста це найдорожчі моменти.
ми їх позбавляємо себе, тому що ми зависаємо
у зомбі ящики у фейкових каналах коли я
читала перші дні канал Верховної Ради
що вирішено раз верховної ради і коли
вони через там пару постів ой соррі це
фейк та
я розумію що вони не хотіли ввести в розум
ну так вийшло тому що тому що
не дарма існує розуміння що змі це
4 сил вона завоювала цей статус і я
розумію що ось щоразу коли в
моменті відбувається щось роботи
емоційний стан тяжкий потрібний
завжди питає, а що трапилося
об'єктивно що трапилося треба називати
своє почуття і я боюся чого ти боїшся
я боюся, що я помру
є загроза смерті, що я можу зробити з
щоб не померти ось є несучі
стіни ось є ванна ось є укриття
синові реальне укриття тому що
величезна кількість людей лізуть з
підвали які стануть природними
могильником чи люди ринком я навчаю
всякі панельні просто впадають
в гаражі металеві люди лізуть
давайте нехай будемо швидко їхати
тікати ось коли люди почнуть
замислюватися що трапилося а що нічого
не трапилося чого я боюся що може
статися а це сталося зараз у мене
є час цього уникнути що я повинен
зробити для того, щоб це не сталося
і як його переводиш свій стан
психічної активності генерації дикої
паніки і як починаєш думати давайте
повертатися в мозок, а потім там техніку
ще як повертатися через тіло, що ти
розумієш
ось у моменті насправді ні
підстав
і
давайте стежити за тим, що відбувається
справді у нас на вулиці, бо
ну навіть ядерну бомбу, коли ти читаєш
що кнопка не тільки в однієї людини та
ми ось припускаємо що він зійшов сума у
мене є такі підстави відчуття, але
кнопка не тільки у нього і як би його не
боялися все одно в момент атаки
враховуючи що за ті не затягне раніше
всього російські міста то швидше за все
ні простіше коли ти все це обдумаєш
радіус та поглинання щось не повністю
і вся україна ці вся україна то тоді і
Європи і тоді ну коротше там залучено
дуже велика кількість процес так
починаєш аналізувати та думати
напевно ні стріляти ти почуєш це з
вікон якщо ти почуєш із вікон ти встигнеш
сховатись і ти тоді вже починаєш це
випускати розуміти та відчувають тому що
у
мене дуже багато друзів зараз з
харкова і вони звичайно знаходиться в дуже
тяжкому стані ось я сьогодні у
переконувала свого друга терміново відвозити
свою сім'ю ось вони всі ці дні
знаходилися ось у цьому жахливому стані і
ось вони виїхали а є друзі які
сидять у затишних місцях горять страшно але
ми в безпеці ось бач яка різна
реальність один харків за різною
реальності
для
даних bespeco циви їх від і хоча чоловіки
вагони народжують себе ціна на небі speck
у чоловіків, а ще народжуючих, знаходитесь там у
підвалі щоб ми схожі за допомогою еге
bsp до того що ми захищені язичну можна
так би мовити і для одного
хіральність
правди у справні для іншого так санки
та й треба весь час ти знаєш розумієте
що світ великий а я маленький і це
добре тому що раз я маленький означає
я у себе є і я можу сховатися
люди здебільшого чомусь
вирішують я розумію чому тому що у нас
є психології є таке поняття
комплекс бога ми всі вважаємо що світ
зосереджений на нас тому у мирне
час починаємо полірувати своїх дітей
своїх чоловіків своїх дружин ви начальником
починай перевіряти ще раз але насправді
світу чхати на тебе ось тобі має бути
не чхати на себе, бо ти в себе
є і ось потрібно постійно поговорити
всередині себе я у себе є я впораюся
ось це повернення до себе не зовні що
це бачу як за мною спостерігає що я
міг зробити для себе тут і зараз
чи достатньо у мене їжі чи достатньо у
мене води і все тобі страшно збери
тривожна валізка якщо тобі страшно
списком форма в комфортному спортивному
костюмі обіймайся весь час стінка з
кимось поруч може бути не треба з цим
людиною виходь заміж це прекрасний
спосіб зрозуміти це з кимось побіжимо це
не те з ким хочеться пробувати ховатися
у бункері а може бути навпаки
і лаявся і ми витрачаємо час на суперечки та
конфлікти
а ось тут і зараз перебуваючи тривожне
час депо ось саме з цією людиною я
хочу провести останню живуть з цим
людиною я хочу укриття і тоді не
витрачайте час обіймайтеся і цілуйтесь
робіть нових людей дивіться цікаві
фільми та завішувати та вікна тобто
мінімальні заходи безпеки все одно
повинні бути зроблені ось на них потрібно
зосередити і як тільки ти зробив
поставив собі галочку свій папірець або в
голові у мене зібрана валіза там
достатньо продуктів у мене є аптечка
я знаю як бігти я знаю куди їхати моя
машина заправлена ​​або я знаю, як тут не
знаю де ховатися і все видихніть
тому що більше ви для себе нічого не
зможете зробити вся аналітика
військових дій знову таки теж я
начиталася з тих хто пройшов війну вони
всі кажуть що найбільша кількість
людей гине на вулицях у паніці втекти
тобто замість того, щоб піддавати
своє життя реальної небезпеки знаходитесь
у реальній безпеці ось не дарма ж
є вираз думаю і стіни допомагають
це ж не про мирний час це ж про
війну ти знаєш я не знаю
чи вірити в реінкарнацію я не знаю
взагалі нічого не знаю взагалі ми не знаємо
про рай чи пекло в харкові від людей бояться
так ось у нас тут ось я думаю що якщо
справді були якісь
перетворення то
наші тіла наші вірніше душі прожили
досить велика кількість воєн і вони
знають як їх переживати і ось треба ось
відчути в моменті не про не не
проживаючи ось ці інформаційні дикі
потоки, які ми поглинаємо
що що я ось відчуваю що я думаю про
цьому й ось аналізувати ситуацію не
через призму всього того, що мені сказали
хто що розповіді треба бігти треба
рятуватися ні треба ховатись це пройде
ні це назавжди відчути що я
можу зробити для себе для зростання та
розвитку з любов'ю тут і зараз тому
що мені здається що він ну ось тварини
взагалі розвиваються через біль і мені
здається що ця дика ситуація
яка відбувається вона дана нам потім
для обнулення у нас у країні відбувалися
абсолютно дикі незрозумілі процеси
останні довгі роки війна дуже сильно
разу бджола нас спочатку моїм даними немає
спочатку революцією потім майданом
чотирнадцятому році і ось ми весь час
знаходимося на вигляд з вакцинацією дуже
сильно до поділяв те, що не розділилася
і зараз найстрашніше що я бачу що
відбувається відбувається тотальне
поділ люди розлучаються розходяться
перестають спілкуватися з друзями зі
знайомими та найстрашніше до чого
повинна була привести це в я
прийду цей поділ це сварка
ось є дуже крутий експеримент
який пояснює те, що відбувається з
нами оскільки невеликий чоловічок ось
якщо помістити
щури або ось мурах поміщали чорних і
червоних в одну банку і бігали про хортів
ми взаємодіяли ігнорували друг
другові один одного будували колонії один з
другом вони все-таки трохи різні але
вони абсолютно не комплектували
необхідні один одного то взяли в
експериментальному потрясли сильно банку
і чорні та червоні мурахи почали жерти
один одного
банку струсили і люди ніяк не можуть
зрозуміти що ми живемо один одного тому
що нас дуже потужно струснули
і мені дуже сподобалася травм ми з моїми
друзями допомагали щось обороні розвозити
продукти ми це щодня робимо наш
хто як може таки допомагати я допомагаю
психологічний обсяг ринку оборони я
розповім продукти і я зустріла свого
другом там тривога була сирена і ми
пішли в укриття і ми розмовляли і
раптом він шахісток дуже крутий angry
ти знаєш коли знаходиш коли ти
шахівниця то ти ненавидиш інших
шахових фігур
але ж гравці насправді дружать
які сідають за цю шахівницю і
ось ми перебуваючи в стані пішаків ми ж
навіть не коні не володіння ферзою на пішаку
ми ніяк не можемо зрозуміти що все що
відбувається зараз це для того, щоб
гризлися для того, щоб ось ці ось
муроме які перегризли і у тих хто
струснув банку це чудово виходить
і я ось зараз дуже хотіла б щоб
люди які нас дивляться не от задали
собі питання а
навіщо ця війна в моєму житті від чого
вона повинна мене очистити що я повинен
припинити робити у своєму житті, а це
дуже легко зрозуміти просто задайте собі
питання ось що я радий не робити з ким я
радий не спілкуватися що хорошого сталося у
моєму такому ув'язненні це не дурний
питання я впроваджую води і щоб поганого не
відбувається завдяки цій війні, а це
значить ми все це закон цей від
закінчиться найстрашніший від якого
тривало у 2 світову війну це було дуже
довго затяжна війна він закінчився і ми
онуки хтось може бути діти ось тих
людей які вижили у цю другу
світову все минає і це теж пройде
і дуже важливо які сенси ми набудемо
у цю війну наскільки ми станемо сильнішими
і міцніше мудріше найголовніше на
любовний бо ось такий великий
людина
психолог філософ віктор франкл який
був у гетто і він сам естонською так
був свідком експериментів і потім
напрям психології зробив і ось він
довів що
тільки ті люди, які
мали сенс вижити вони виживали та
ось найменше кожен ось у
кожного піднімається буде взагалі багато
сьогодні суперечливих речей говорю
несуперечливих вірніше а ті які
викликають швидше всі дивні відчуття, але
сенс жити і прожити у всіх є ось
ти знаєш коли я запитую люди
чомусь думають що якщо вони бояться
смерті значить вони хочуть жити, а це
різна абсолютно різна коли я
питаю а ось який вам сенс жити ось
що ви робитимете коли ви вийдете з
бункера з війни
суші люди не знають що відповідає
ну житиму так то він і бояться
простому покараю чисто ну чого вони не
розуміють
що за ним будувати можна так сказати це
не просто бояться б про нього ні вони бояться
втратити те білкові існування тут
здійснила не живих ж дукова тіл
який ми представляємо ти розумієш ось
до війни я
займалася
психосоматика та
особистісним зростанням корпоративним
коучингом і я весь час намагалася
привести людей до цього смислового
розуміння себе і чим ти можеш бути
корисний людям не тільки собі ось знаєш
я завжди єхидничать самі були
поширені тренінги як заробити
гроші ти як знайти з ким сперечається
умовно кажучи кохання не ніхто не шукав
тренінг як стати корисним іншому
людині і в мене склалося відчуття
зараз я в ньому переконуюсь що ось як у
генерації грошей у своєму житті і точно
також генерації життя у собі
первісні питання та життєтворно
наскільки ти життя твій ринг для цього
людської маси наскільки ти можеш
бути корисним іншим і ось тоді тебе як
мурахи не струснуть, бо ти
корисний тому що ти виділяєш
певна кількість кохання від якої
можуть погрітися інші
ось ти зараз перебуваєш у квартирі зі
своїми рідними всі, хто нас дивляться вони
перебувають чи самі із собою і це сама
сумна ізоляція дуже погано впливає на
психіку чи не перебуває зі своїми
близькими ви поставте і мінімальний
питання поставте мету давайте думати
сьогоднішнім днем ​​і тоді завтра точно
поступиться що корисного я можу зробити для
інших
це як мінімум не сваритися це як
мінімум не видавати кількість та порту
не заражати я дам не заражати страхом не
втекти один одному з цими новинами ось
ось це прочитав ось це подивися що
відбувається люди це дуже страшно що
відбувається скрізь але заразіть чимось
хорошим знайдіть якийсь позитивний
ролик і у відповідь коли вам надішлють
якусь чергову жорсткість чергову
страху поглинач чергую
інформаційну бомбу у відповідь надішліть
якийсь ролик 95 кварталу якийсь
мімчик щось реально смішно і тому
що наше з вами завдання у кожного з нас
це вижити за рахунок кохання, тому що світ
врятує зовсім не краса ваша краса
очах того, хто дивиться у світ, врятує любов
якщо ти любиш життя ось по-справжньому
є ще раз повторююсь різниці боятися
смерті
це акцент на смерті це акцент на йаді
на агресії ось це те, що в чому ми
закопуємо нас усіх зараз провокує
на ненависть вони вона важить
руйнівної енергії це отруйна вона
руйнує не їх їм все одно вони
годуються на вас руйнує вас шумить у
вухах це не настя і зовсім інше я
вибираю життя ось життя це кохання ми
народилися від кохання ось ми колись ось
це ось клітинка почала ділитися тому
що ми це дотик любові в
моменті тата і мами і ось цього кохання
пішло наше життя і ось ці паростки
які зараз ми всі представляємо я
вважаю, що треба поливати виключно
любов'ю і тиражування їхнє кохання і ось
тоді ми вижили тому що тоді ми
життєтворно і тут продовження ct за
вчора у нас було 20 хаффера вокалом
обриву protect і допомагати їм можна бути
акуратним сьогодні і армії Ісус піцу в
село моя головна ідея простий ще cool та
ти нічого не робот просто зверху через
нові дані так далі там він покарає
чити випадаєш з усього інфо поля хоче
там переживаєш не приживається nikuman та
на важливі в цьому удари наймаючи виходу
реального праворуч акули туди допомагаєш
авантюристом допам його іштар обороні
навчаєшся обидва в кібер фронті опиняюся
прибираєш там долі нехай не знаю просто
там sidcash
значок last тут же ти вже все та будь-якого
виду своєї там до своїх друзів до своєї
Батьківщини не знаю та чого заводу до
свого сусіда там вичавки ти вже з
робот головне з любов'ю ось головне це
робити з будь-якою вниз ненавистю прогулянок
я завжди говорю що навіть якщо ти взяв
зброя захищати свою сім'ю то чітко
відчуваєш ти захищаєш сім'ю вони ти
ненавидиш того кого ти та ти вистрілиш
нього це ну це закон життя, бо
ти захищаєш, але якщо ви відправляєте себе
ненавистю то пам'ятайте про те, щоб той
мураха якого струсили разом з тим
проти кого ви воюєте я нікого не
захищаю і мені боляче спостерігати як
хтось вирішив що він може зайти до нас у
будинок і змусити нас гризти один одного
мені дуже боляче бачити наскільки це
ці шахісти боляче поводяться з нами
ну якщо ми не піддаємося ненависті якщо
ми не захлинається я дам якщо ми не
захлинувся ось цим диким страхом і
ненавистю ось тоді ми виживемо і
давайте з любов'ю плести сітки розвозити
і йду готувати їжу допомагати величезне
кількість людей залишилася за бортом
життя тільки тому, що зараз пішов
акцент на армію і на біженцях, але ми ж
не шукаємо хворих нещасних дітей які
і були до війни і зараз взагалі
повністю від них відвернулися і ми
сьогодні підвантажили у tor оборону їжу вони
знаходяться в пункті переливання крові та
там величезна вивіска крові більше не
треба волонтери у нас всю їй є люди
настільки ж є купа інших людей
давайте допомагати іншим людям теж
їсти треба питати насправді якщо
вам хтось із друзів пише дзвонить і ось
той такий поганий поганий спробуйте його
врівноважить теж гуд користь що сонечко
я з тобою, але все буде добре ми
впораємося і треба буде я всім говорю
пишіть список, чим ви будете займатися
після війни ось закінчилося все
вимкнути у тебе тут випадково
рубильник увімкнули 23
числа ось так само і вимикають
одного разу і ось о 4 ранку ось відчуйте
що ви робитимете з ким ви підете
пити каву може бути ви не знаю собаку
кішку з дуже велика кількість людей
викинула своїх домашніх тварин на
вулицю ці бідні бідолахи повзають по
вулицям не знають куди приткнутися
візьміть якусь кішку і собаку ж
врятуєте чиюсь душу не знаю може ви
підете на малювання може бути ви
потрапите на танці чудово вже там смуті
вдома вже малюйте вже по ці ось дуже
до речі у стресі дуже сильно допомагає
співати особливо якщо поряд малюки для того
щоб не дуріти від сирени
сильно впливає на психіку буде від
раку чи ні ніхто не знає члени
включається про всяк випадок, але паніка
запускає дуже потужні грегор страшно
ось якщо ви почнете в цей момент співати
якщо ви будете спати в беруші якщо ви
будете в безпечне спите але звірят
якщо ви співатимете пісеньки рахувати
лічилочки голосно якщо ви будете слухати
класну класичну музику вона
однозначно вас приведе в поле у ​​коханні та
безпеки ось я дуже багато
раніше читала і віктор франкл для мене
дуже сильний авторитет і зараз усі
час попадаю на ці
записи наукових досліджень у самих
диких умовах ось прямий у найжорстокішій в
надзвичайних умовах у другу світову
війну виживали ті, хто молився і ті
які відчували ось таку ось
глобальне кохання та силу духу
присутність панове у собі навіть якщо ви
не вірите відчуваєте всесвіту
відчуваєте ось цю енергетику
дух собі і ось знаєш я я чоловік не права
може бути
dur білих подивимося далі у мене один
за одним виїжджають з одеси мої друзі я
залишаюсь я тому це знаєш ось я мені
здається я ніколи не був такий сильний
як зараз може бути це тому, що я
відчуваю відповідальність допомагати людям
і
абсолютно чужі люди які я створила
чат у телеграмі антипаніка та весь час
перебуваю на зв'язку і ось мені постійно
пишуть леночка ви не уявляєте як я
вам вдячна що ви пишете що я вдома
тому що там я одна з дитиною у мене
немає можливості виїхати або ось хтось
там дуже багато ль але і жінок залишилися
дітьми чоловіки пройшли таро оборони не
панічно бояться це що я говорю я вдома
їм вселяє ось миша-людина
ну як їй можу цим допомогти ну ось вони
видихають і вони спокійно йдуть робити кашу
своїм дітям годувати своїх чоловіків синів
яких вони ховають молодців
поговорю якщо ви не готові воювати не
їдіть тому що ви м'ясо воювати повинні
і ті, хто відчуває в собі силу духу
а ось аби бігти ось як я не люблю
коли засуджую тих, хто втік і не люблю
коли засуджую ті, хто не пішов воювати і
не люблю коли люди взагалі в принципі
опускаються до засудження, бо
кожен веде сюди тому що він може себе
вести і ось якщо ми відчуємо що це
його життя це його вибір, а ось я тут я
у себе є те, що я можу зробити для
себе і для своїх близьких із любов'ю то
це дасть сенс їхнього життя і ми виживемо це
я прям обіцяю і знаєш доведеш продажів
це в будинку завжди знаходишся і так це
такий же вдома абату ми знаємо з найкращих
києві і я буду чого я тут таке знаєш
як тільки об'єкт виявиш дух і давання
навіть сини Якова та новачків натали
Миколай усі кадри по всій Україні
люди реально я розмішував псини будь-якого
тому ж синові своєму своєму україну своїй
з'їмо і це історія ну просто на йому
вірна енергійно дуже просто вона
пробиваючи абсолютно все і коли тягни і
бігаєш сядай опиняюся в муку але вивіска
вами сковувало може ніби й
волонтерства та граматика позиції тоді
особі нуцці ціна йому повернутися на йому
вірна там я думаю що тут варіанті
клімакс і у нас буде годинник вимкну світло
почекай бо у нас три блага і я
відійду пройшла з правди, у нас нас провели
часто закінчується на вітрі hop рубля та
дам знаєш що давай я дам тільки
техніку для а потім же я ж
психосоматолог та
я допомагаю моя основна до військова місія
це допомагати людям
впоратися з під цими найважчими
магічними штуками в
тілі ось я зараз пропоную всім
відчути де у вас у тілі живе
страх живе тривога живе більше
небезпека у кожного з нас страх він
живе в тілі ось відчуй про говоріть
про себе і розумієш ми тут поговорили
стало легше але скажіть про себе
можете заплющити очі ось начебто на
свободі тут немає і ось скажіть про
себе кілька разів мені страшно я боюся
мені страшно я боюся померти мені страшно
коли ви відчуєте
сильний акцент у тілі вона зазвичай food
грудей або в кому в горлі в основному грудях
страх чому статика вигляд вражає
людей тому що виключу тому що це
навіть світловий ефект мене головне щоб
чути було тому, що коліт це
потужна емоція страху та
коли людина дуже страшно у
нього таке відчуття що
блокують грудну клітину як жаба
задавила як якийсь металевий ком
у грудях ви відчуєте розгляньте як
виглядає ось ця
металева штука може не
металева може каміна як цей
страх відчувається у вас у грудях
перенесіться в серце зараз
відчуйте що у вас у серці
ніжне тепле кохання уявіть кого
завгодно бабусю в дитинстві маму-тату
дитину своєї коханої людини яка
ви колись дуже любили і ви
відчуєте ніжний а тепле відчуття
яка розливається у вас серця
і
тепер відчуєте як поширюється
це тепле світло
за межі серця ось начебто
видихаєте це тепле світло і
починаєте заливати грудну клітину та
починаєте розчиняти
цей страх і розчиняйте ось те, що було
у грудях відчувати як ви заливаєте
теплом
розчиняє це страх і заливайте грудну
клітину теплим світлом та
тепер розливаєте всьому тілу, відчуваєте
як хвиля теплого ніжного світла
поширюється по всьому тілу
і
похитайте як маятники сторони в
бік
згадайте як мама захитувало вас
колись засипали і
так ніби заспокоюйте себе
тепла хвиля
гонка похитує вас
вправо-ліворуч
лего
лема
промовте кінь я у себе є
я впораюся
і сильні а сильно я ваще тобто
і спокійно
легко
і спонукайте в цьому
очищаються стані
так вона
обволікає ланс і прямий проливається
крізь тіло назовні
і є я впораюся
робимо глибоких у
їжа і в цьому стані теплому спокійним
повертаємось до мене я зуби і
6 а фірма не знаєш
ти знаєш і якщо ось у нас є дітки
ось треба ось цей стан пролити
крізь себе та залі дід піднімають
поцілувати швиденько скажу, що потрібно
робити у страху
пити воду дрібними ковтками трястись усім
тілом прямо уявляти що страх
струшують у руки прямо на рахунок сильний
сильно трясти руками-ногами присідати
віджиматися від підлоги від стільниці
постояти в планці прийняти душ вмитися
холодною водою мити обличчя
потерти мочки вуха потерти сильною
різкість 1 сильно зробити масаж
плечового пояса шиї чомусь тому що
страх дуже сильно плечовий пояс
стягує
розтирати ручки собі разом є малюки
поруч розтирати їм нічки вже камінчик і
руки робити ось цю техніку
поширення розливання світла та тепла
і дуже допомагає дихати тобто ось
прямо вимовляти про себе я роблю вдих
або я вдихаю і вдихнути я видихаю
уявити, що начебто в
ніжках міститься кабіна ліфта
наповнена запахом улюблених квітів я
прям проганяємо цю кабіну ліфта можемо
навіть поверхи піднімати до восьми рахувати
треба один на ніжках і 8 на голові і ось
робимо 1 до 8 потім 876 отже
піднімати і лише виду кілька разів
поки не заспокоїться ще дуже добре
допомагає
м'язова активність стискати пальці руки
інтенсивно пресом туди сюди відпочивати
уявляти що в животику міститься
кулька того кольору який прийде голу ви
вдихаєш і збільшується кулька
надувається видихаєте здувається кулька
стискати ноги стискати опу
марширувати на місці і звичайно як я вже
сказала співати та танцювати це примочок
допомагає
україна зодіаку цього душа за те, що
сьогодні було знам і люблять тубі
добраніч і слава україни ми
допоможемо у близького обряд мимо пропоную
щоранку і щовечора як до
зустрічі я вдячна тобі що дав мені
можливість бути корисною такому
кількості людей дякую піджарку
є і мене також будуть крок від цього
рамка на латвії я його дякую тобі
велике завдяки всі слова